WE WILL PROVE TONIGHT WHY SHE IS
ACTUALLY AN AMERICAN HERO.
WE HAVE ALL OF THIS TONIGHT AND
TONIGHT'S OPENING NEWS
MONOLOGUE.
ALL RIGHT, THEY HAVE BEEN PUT ON
NOTICE, AMERICA WILL NO LONGER
BE BOWING DOWN TO THEIR
AGGRESSIVE TACTICS.
THE DAYS OF BLINDLY TRUSTING AND
TRYING TO BRIBE THIS ROGUE
REGIME ARE NOW OVER.
HOURS AGO, PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE
OF THE COURAGEOUS TO PULL THE
UNITED STATES OUT OF THIS VERY
FLAWED IRANIAN NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK HERE.
>> THE IRANIAN REGIME IS THE
THE DEAL ALLOWED I RAN IT TO
CONTINUE ENRICHING URANIUM AND
OVERTIME, REACH THE BRINK OF A
NUCLEAR BREAKOUT.
THIS DISASTROUS DEAL GAVE THIS
REGIME -- AND IT'S A REGIME OF
GREAT TERROR.
MANY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
SOME OF IT IN ACTUAL CASH.
TODAY, WE HAVE DEFINITIVE PROOF
THAT THIS IRANIAN PROMISE WAS
ALL A LIE.
THEREFORE, I AM ANNOUNCING TODAY
THAT THE UNITED STATES WILL
WITHDRAW FROM THE IRAN AT
NUCLEAR DEAL.
>> Sean: THANK GOD.
NOW, NATURALLY, THE IRANIAN
PRESIDENT, HE RESPONDED WITH THE
THROAT SAYING THAT HIS ROGUE
REGIME, THEY ARE READY TO START
ENRICHING AN UNLIMITED AMOUNT OF
URANIUM IF THE SECONDARY
NEGOTIATIONS DO NOT YIELD
POSITIVE RESULTS.
NOW, THIS EXPRESSION MAY HAVE
WORKED WITH OBAMA, BUT NOT
ANYMORE.
THIS IS A NEW AGE OF DIPLOMACY,
BASED ON THE CONCEPT THAT REAGAN
TAUGHT US.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
IT WORKS.
WATCH THIS.
>> AS WE EXIT TO THE IRAN DEAL,
WE WILL BE WORKING WITH OUR
ALLIES TO FIND OUR REAL
COMPREHENSIVE AND LASTING
SOLUTION TO THE IRANIAN NUCLEAR
THREAT.
IN THE MEANTIME, POWERFUL
SANCTIONS WILL GO INTO FULL
EFFECT.
IF THE REGIME CONTINUES ITS
NUCLEAR ASPIRATIONS, IT WILL
HAVE BIGGER PROBLEMS THAN IT HAS
EVER HAD BEFORE.
>> Sean: IT NOW, OF COURSE, IF
IRAN IS SERIOUS ABOUT MAKING THE
IMMEDIATELY HALTING THEIR EFFORS
TO DESTROY THE UNITED STATES,
THERE WOULD STILL BE TIME TO
NEGOTIATE.
MOST U.S. SANCTIONS WILL NOT BE
REINSTATED FOR ANOTHER 90 DAYS.
OIL RELATED SANCTIONS WILL TAKE
180 DAYS TO COME ONLINE.
BUT LET'S BE CLEAR.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WILLING AND
READY TO NEGOTIATE, JUST LIKE HE
IS WITH LITTLE ROCKET MAN.
TAKE A LOOK.
BECAUSE THE FACT IS, THEY ARE
GOING TO WANT TO MAKE A NEW AND
LASTING DEAL.
ONE THAT BENEFITS ALL OF IRAN
AND THE IRANIAN PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY DO, I AM READY,
WILLING, AND ABLE.
GREAT THINGS CAN HAPPEN FOR IRAN
GREAT THINGS CAN HAPPEN FOR IRA
IRAN.
AND GREAT THINGS CAN HAPPEN FOR
THE PEACE AND STABILITY THAT WE
ALL WANT IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
TO BE ONE ALL RIGHT, IT IS
REALLY SIMPLE.
IF IRAN WANTS HIS PEOPLE TO
PROSPER WITHOUT THE BURDEN OF
U.S. SANCTIONS, THEY JUST HAVE
TO COME TO THE TABLE.
NOW, THE LEADERS OF IRAN, THEY
ARE CORRUPT, THEY ARE IMMORAL,
THEY ARE RADICAL.
THIS IS A ROGUE THEOCRACY, AND
THEIR SUFFERING PEOPLE KNEW
HERE IS WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD
TO SAY ABOUT THAT VERY SUBJECT
ALSO EARLIER TODAY IN THIS
HISTORIC SPEECH.
>> I WANT TO DELIVER A MESSAGE
TO THE SUFFERING PEOPLE OF IRAN.
THE PEOPLE OF AMERICA STAND WITH
YOU.
IT HAS NOW BEEN ALMOST 40 YEARS
SINCE THIS DICTATORSHIP SEIZED
POWER AND TOOK A PROUD NATION
HOSTAGE.
MOST OF IRAN'S 80 MILLION
CITIZENS HAS SADLY NEVER KNOWN
AND IRAN THAT PROSPERED WITH ITS
NEIGHBORS AND DEMANDED THE --
JOHN CAREY OF COURSE HAS BEEN
BUSY TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BY
CONDUCTING A POTENTIALLY ILLEGAL
SHUTTER DIPLOMACY.
HE SAID THE IRAN DEAL MADE OUR
ALLIES AGREE.
RELEASED AN INCREDIBLY BORING A
HOLIER THOU SANCTIMONIOUS
STATEMENT CALLING THE
PRESIDENT'S DECISION MISGUIDED.
WE WILL SPARE YOU ALL THOSE
BORING DETAILS.
THIS COUNTRY DOES NOT NEED IT
DIPLOMATIC INPUT FROM A
PRESIDENT WHO OVERSAW THE
COLLAPSE OF THE MIDDLE EAST, THE
UNFETTERED EXPANSION OF RUSSIAN
AGGRESSION, AND A SITUATION ON
THE KOREAN PENINSULA THAT WAS
TOTALLY OUT OF CONTROL.
OH, AND HE GAVE THEM
150 BILLION.
OF COURSE, WHILE DEMOCRATS ARE
COMPLAINING, AMERICA'S CLOSEST
ALLEY IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
ISRAEL, IS UNDER A DAILY
IMMINENT THREAT FROM IRAQ.
THEY ARE PLOTTING THE
PRESIDENT'S DECISION.
HERE'S WHAT THE ISRAELI
PRIME MINISTER HAD TO SAY ABOUT
THE PRESENT.
>> FULLY SUPPORTS
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS DECISION
TODAY TO REJECT THE DISASTROUS
NUCLEAR DEAL WITH IRAN.
I OPPOSED IT FROM THE START
BECAUSE WE SAID THAT RATHER THAN
BLOCKING IRAN, IT ACTUALLY PAVES
THE WAY TO AN ENTIRE ARSENAL.
ISRAEL THINKS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID A HISTORIC
MOVE.
AND THIS IS WHY ISRAEL THANKS
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HIS COMMITMENT TO CONFRONT THE
TERRORIST REGIME IN IRAN, AND
HIS COMMITMENT TO ENSURE THAT IT
IRAN NEVER GETS NUCLEAR WEAPONS,
NOT TODAY, NOT IN THE DECADE,
NOT EVER.
>> Sean: IT WAS JUST LAST WEEK
THAT THE PRIME MINISTER REVEALED
IRAN'S NUCLEAR PLAN, CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP A WEAPON SYSTEM THAT IS
CAPABLE OF DELIVERING NUCLEAR
WARHEADS.
STILL, WAY BEFORE HE WENT PUBLIC
WITH THIS INTELLIGENCE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD PROMISED IT
TO SCRAP WHAT A TERRIBLE DEAL HE
HAD INHERITED.
HE KEPT HIS PROMISE.
WATCH THIS.
>> MY NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS TO
DISMANTLE THE DISASTROUS DEAL
WITH IRAN.
I HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS A LONG
TIME, I KNOW DEALMAKING.
AND LET ME TELL YOU, THIS DEAL
IS CATASTROPHIC.
FOR AMERICA, FOR ISRAEL, AND FOR
THE WHOLE OF THE MIDDLE EAST.
THIS WAS JUST PRIOR TO THE
SIGNING OF THE IRAN DEAL, WHICH
GIVE BACK TO IRAN $150 BILLION
AND GAVE US ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
IT WILL GO DOWN IN HISTORY AS
ONE OF THE WORST DEALS EVER
NEGOTIATED.
NEVER, EVER EVER IN MY LIFE HAVE
I SEEN ANY TRANSACTION SO
INCOMPETENTLY NEGOTIATED AS A
DEAL WITH THE IRAN.
AND I MEAN NEVER.
>> Sean: NOT TONIGHT, THE
PRESIDENT IS FULFILLING THAT
VERY IMPORTANT CAMPAIGN PROCESS
AFTER YEARS OF BOWING DOWN TO
DICTATORS, KISSING THEIR RINGS,
ONCE AGAIN ON THE WORLD STAGE OF
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE IF
HISTORY HAS TAUGHT US ANYTHING,
IT IS THAT APPEASEMENT NEVER
WORKS.
YOU MAY REMEMBER NEVILLE
CHAMBERLAIN.
HE WAS A BRITISH PRIME MINISTER,
DECLARING PEACE AND OUR TIME
AFTER CAVING IN DURING
NEGOTIATIONS AFTER MEETING
HITLER AND MUNICH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE SETTLEMENTS OF THE
PROBLEM, WHICH IS NOW BEEN
ACHIEVED IS IN MY VIEW ONLY THE
PRELUDE TO A LARGER SETTLEMENT
IN WHICH ALL OF EUROPE MAY FIND